[Musica]
buonasera a tutti questa sera io partirò
da queste tre immagini che vedete dietro
di me il tar skoff 2 un domino una
squadra di calcio
ecco ma cosa c'entrano queste tre
immagini qual è il legame cosa ci stanno
a fare insieme è esattamente quello che
cercherò di svelarvi questo pomeriggio
ma andiamo per gradi
partiamo dalla prima immagine
purtroppo non potevo che partire da qua
dopo questi lunghi anni di convivenza
con la pandemia da cove di 19
l'immagine del sar skoff 2 questo virus
questa pandemia che ha fortemente
sconquassato la nostra esistenza
penso a chi ha affrontato direttamente
la malattia con i sintomi le ricadute da
un punto di vista medico sanitario ma
anche psicologico penso a chi purtroppo
ha subito dei lutti non potendo nemmeno
accompagnare degnamente per l'ultimo
saluto il proprio caro ma penso anche a
quelle professioni che hanno continuato
a lavorare le professioni essenziali che
anche durante i picchi della pandemia
hanno continuato a prestare la loro
opera nonostante i momenti di incertezza
nonostante la minaccia per la loro vita
penso ai medici gli infermieri gli
operatori sanitari ma penso in realtà
anche a chi lavora chi ha lavorato nei
supermercati nei trasporti coloro che ci
hanno permesso di mantenere una qualche
qualità di vita ma penso anche a chi ha
visto ridimensionare la propria attività
professionale
la propria attività commerciale non solo
per la pandemia ma soprattutto per le
misure di contenimento
e poi penso a noi a tutti noi che siamo
così cambiati nella nostra vita
quotidiana nel nostro lavoro nel nostro
modo di insegnare di apprendere per via
di questa pandemia e per via di tutto
ciò che ne è conseguito insomma una
pandemia che ha fortemente segnato tutti
noi come singoli e come società dal
punto di vista emotivo psicologico e
sanitario sociale
una pandemia però che c'è anche lasciato
un insegnamento
e cioè che ci ha insegnato che ogni
nostra singola scelta comportamentale in
realtà se è importantissima perché può
avere delle ricadute
inaspettate e drammatica e me per la
salute personale per la salute
collettiva e addirittura per la tenuta
del sistema sanitario
ecco esattamente come il domino abbiamo
capito il valore dei nostri
comportamenti
perché se ci pensiamo ancora oggi ancora
dopo due anni di pandemia di fatto
l'unico vero farmaco per fermare la
diffusione dei contagi è stato il
cambiamento comportamentale
pensiamo a quelle tre singh simp
semplici regole che abbiamo dovuto in
qualche modo
imparare ad applicare nella nostra vita
quotidiana
la mascherina lavarsi spesso le mani
mantenere dissestamento sociale insomma
tra e semplicissime regole
normate sanzionate ripetute e comunque
estremamente e faticose da accettare
nella nostra quotidianità
ma pensiamo anche ai vaccini vaccini
anti co vide 19 questi vaccini così
fortemente sperati anelati questi
vaccini che sono stati anche spesso
oggetto di dibattito vituperati questi
vaccini che la scienza è riuscita a
creare con un miracolo di ricerca
incredibile
con questi dati di efficacia e di
sicurezza molto alti ma che ancora una
volta per raggiungere il massimo della
loro efficacia hanno necessità del
nostro cambiamento comportamentale
perché se non aderiamo alla campagna
vaccinale anche il vaccino non funziona
ecco quindi sostanzialmente quello che
vi vorrei dire è che i nostri
comportamenti questi nostri
comportamenti e soprattutto il
cambiamento dei nostri comportamenti
e così faticoso ma è anche così
estremamente importante fondamentale
ma fatemi fare un piccolo test qui in
sala
chi ha almeno una volta ha tentato di
smettere di fumare alzi la mano
e che almeno una volta si è iscritto a
un programma sportivo ma poi non lo ha
concluso
e chi almeno una volta non ha pensato di
cambiare il regime dietetico e poi ha
sgarrato
esattamente qual punto se anche lasciamo
la pandemia da cover di 19 ma guardiamo
alle nostre abitudini di vita quotidiana
il punto è esattamente questo perché un
conto è avere l'intenzione di cambiare
il nostro comportamento
un altro contrazione insomma tra
l'intenzione l'azione ci sta di mezzo al
mare effettivamente o meglio no ci sta
di mezzo della psicologia è esattamente
questo di cui si occupa la psicologia
cioè che cosa ci può essere tra il
pianificare il volere l'aver en
intenzione desiderio di cambiare e poi
il cambiare
effettivamente
beh come sono stata presentata io sono
una psicologa
e sono quasi sicura che molti di voi a
questa parola abbiano iniziato ad
immaginare una situazione tipo questa un
paziente sul lettino sulla sedia un
terapeuta che fa le domande o forse
anche sta zitto prende punti fa la
diagnosi insomma effettivamente questa è
la situazione più classica è anche una
delle più importanti quella dove c'è una
psicoterapia dove c'è un approccio di
psicologia clinica che affronta la
patologia e cerca di dare un supporto
per superarla
però mi spiace deludervi
non sono io io sono una psicologa non
così
di cosa mi occupo
provo a dirvelo con una metafora
avete presente il cappellaio matto
quello della favola di alice nel paese
delle meraviglie
beh il cappellaio matto disvela ad alice
una cosa importante cioè che non ci sono
soltanto i compleanni da festeggiare ma
ci sono un sacco di non compleanni che
quindi tutto sommato si può fare
attenzione anche a quei giorni
quotidiani che sono in non compleanni
nella mia metafora la psicologia di cui
mi occupo e che voglio svelarvi
quest'oggi è proprio quella psicologia
dei non comportamenti cioè la psicologia
della nostra vita quotidiana la nostra
normalità delle nostre abitudini di ciò
che ci rende così refrattari a cambiare
così refrattari ad aderire a delle
prescrizioni di cambiare il nostro
comportamento
ed è proprio questa psicologia che in
qualche modo se torniamo anche al
discorso di prima
ha
sfidato molto anche nella prevenzione da
cove di 19 ecco ritorniamo un attimo al
discorso di prima la prevenzione queste
misure preventive questa difficoltà ad
aderire a cambiare il nostro
comportamento
beh gran parte della scienza
epidemiologica e anche della psicologia
della salute e dice che tutto dipende da
quanto effettivamente ci sentiamo
minacciati
da un pericolo da un rischio e questo
sicuramente diventa un momento
importante per cambiare il nostro
comportamento
ok ma andiamo per gradi allora un conto
effettivamente è il pericolo pericolo è
un fattore oggettivo è un fattore
chimico biologico e naturale come si
diceva prima è ciò che effettivamente
potrebbe minacciare la nostra salute
ma poi spesso parliamo di rischio quanto
siamo a rischio di quel pericolo ma il
rischio è già tutto un altro discorso
perché il rischio è un calcolo di
probabilità che quel pericolo
effettivamente avvenga e che 15 minacce
e sin qua
ok ma in realtà quello che davvero può
motivare o meno il nostro cambiamento
comportamentale è la percezione del
rischio è già in questa parola della
percezione avete capito quanto ci sta di
psicologico perché non è soltanto la
percentuale di quel fattore biologico
naturale che si presenterà mai di quanto
noi diamo significato quella percentuale
è quindi una percezione che fortemente
dipende dalle nostre esperienze
pregresse dal nostro punto di vista dai
nostri valori dalle nostre preferenze da
come in qualche modo andiamo ad
interpretare quel dato e sta proprio qua
che c'è un mondo di psicologia un mondo
di psicologia appunto dei non
comportamenti che cerca in qualche modo
di decriptare quelle che sono le varie
tendenze che stanno dietro a un
comportamento
e quindi qual è la soluzione
la soluzione è difficile da darla ma su
questo devo fare un passo indietro e vi
racconto o da dove ho iniziato la mia
professione
io sono una psicologa dei consumi e ho
iniziato a lavorare nell'ambito della
ricerca di mercato per il marketing che
ho iniziato ad appassionarmi di fronte a
un fenomeno molto evidente è che anche
tocca me stessa cioè perché certe volte
ci appassioniamo fortemente verso certi
prodotti o verso certe marche tanto che
continuiamo ad acquistare il prodotto di
quella marca ma tanto che quella marca
diventa parte della nostra quotidianità
quasi un alleato un amico quasi le mani
siamo quella marca quel prodotto
non possiamo immaginare la nostra
abitudine di vita senza quel prodotto
ecco questo sono sicura che è capitato
anche a voi non soltanto a me e io ho
iniziato a studiarlo perché tecnicamente
questo viene chiamato consumer
engagement cioè effettivamente quanto il
consumatore riesca ad essere ingaggiato
accalappiato dalla marca e questo devo
dirvi che è un fenomeno che non soltanto
studiamo molto nella ricerca di mercato
ma in cui anche le aziende il marketing
molto lavorano proprio per alimentare
questo legame è di fatto per alimentare
un cambiamento comportamentale cioè il
fatto che continuiamo ad acquistare quel
prodotto e allora ho iniziato da qua è
iniziato a lavorare su questo iniziato a
fare ricerca per capire quali potessero
essere delle strategie commerciali di
marketing di pubblicità che potessero
agganciare consumatore ma poi dato che
come avete capito dall'inizio del mio
speech la mia passione è quello della
salute della sanità ho iniziato a
chiedermi perché come questo concetto
magari non potesse essere
traslato al mondo della sanità e della
salute e quindi non potesse essere quell
elemento che in qualche modo ci aiuta a
cambiare comportamento per la
prevenzione
allora iniziato un po studiare che cosa
ci possa essere di psicologico dietro a
questa in gage mente del consumatore del
cittadino ma cerco di far velo semplice
ma avete mai cercato su instagram ahimè
ngage oppure sul dizionario di oxford
cosa vuol dire engagement beh il
significato è molto semplice e rimanda
ad un'esperienza di passione è
un'esperienza di legame un'esperienza in
cui c'è poco di mentale ma c'è molto di
sé motivo si getta il cuore oltre
all'ostacolo e si fa un progetto un
progetto di vita insieme si costruisce
una alleanza una partnership e voi mi
direte e che c'entra tutto questo con la
medicina al coronavirus la pandemia che
ci sa fare ma in realtà c'entra c'entra
anche qua perché vuol dire in qualche
modo che quando veramente riusciamo a
cambiare la nostra identità riusciamo a
sentirci parte di un progetto di un
progetto che ci modifica nei nostri
obiettivi che ci appassiona un progetto
in cui diventiamo parte di una squadra
perché penso che siamo tutti d'accordo
nel ritenere che la medicina oggi che la
sanità oggi sia frutto di un lavoro di
squadra perché ci sono i medici gli
infermieri e gli psicologi ma perché ci
sono tantissimi diversi operatori che
insieme lavorano per curarci al meglio
ecco se questo è vero allora è arrivato
il momento che anche il paziente anche
il cittadino anche tutti noi non stiamo
in panchina ma capiamo che siamo parte
di questa squadra che siamo parte di
questo progetto che siamo parte di
questa finalità e questo sì che può
essere ciò che ci svela la modalità di
ingaggiarci verso un progetto comune
quindi che ci motiva a modificare i
nostri comportamenti ed è quello che
tornando alla pandemia da cover di 19
può esattamente essere ciò che blocca
quel domino di contagio contagio emotivo
innanzitutto di contagio psicologico di
delega verso il cambiamento del nostro
comportamento e ci fa tornare davvero
protagonisti delle nostre scelte davvero
consapevoli delle nostre scelte davvero
capaci di modificarle per raggiungere un
obiettivo comune
così è se vi pare
[Applauso]